make that decision very early on but
we'll be making additional decisions as
they arise I guess Tony what about
closing the southern borders that's
still on the table we're not looking at
it very strongly we're not seeing a lot
of evidence in that area we're closing
in I guess automatically because we have
a very strong border there now we didn't
have a strong border at all we've built
129 miles of wall and the wall area is
100% secure but we haven't seen any
great I don't think we've seen any great
evidence of that areas of problem at
this moment so we won't have to bother
with that at this moment anybody you're
so nice today watching the primaries
that are taking place well it's going to
be a very interesting evening of
television I think it's really going to
be something that's got some races going
on that didn't seem to exist a few days
ago and now vibe has come up a little
bit and I don't know what's happened
with Bernie I think they're trying to
take it away from them I don't know if
that's fair but I guess it's politics
when you get right down to it what's
fair but I think it's going to be a very
interesting evening of television and
because of the time difference
California time difference it's going to
go a little bit later than we're
accustomed to right and I will be
watching who would I like to win anybody
I'll take anybody I have to that's the
way it's got to work doesn't matter I
really just you know we've done a great
job we have the strongest economy on
earth we we've gone up and you know as
you know China's economy has been hurt
very badly long before this we've done a
really good job and I think people
understand that and I'm looking at polls
that are very good but you know whoever
it is it is will take them on we have no
choice right anything else they do have
a reaction to the North Korean launch of
those missiles yesterday no I have no
reaction short-term missiles no no and
and back on the Afghanistan was that
your first conversation with the leader
of the Taliban
I don't want to say that but we had a
very good conversation with the leader
of the Taliban today and they're looking
to get this ended and we're looking to
get it ended I think we all have a very
common interest we'll find out about the
country itself but the country really
has to get it ended we've been there for
20 years
the presidents have tried to they have
been unable to get any kind of an
agreement the relationship is very good
that I have with the mullah and we had a
good long conversation today and you
know they want to cease the violence
they'd like to see silence also the
Afghan government seems reluctant to
turn over those five thousand prisoners
they may be reluctant you know they've
done very well with the United States
for many years far beyond military if
you look at all the money that we've
spent in Afghanistan we've spent
trillions of dollars trillions of
dollars and we're really a police force
were really not fighting per se it's a
fight that if we had to we'd win but I
don't want to kill millions of people
would win it fairly quickly but I don't
want to kill millions of people I think
it's crazy and so we've been that will
be very very soon it'll be 20 years and
I said right from the beginning not easy
to get out of these conflicts very
complex in terms of all of the people
you have to deal with including frankly
people in the Senate people in the house
and a lot of people feel differently
about things but I've been amazed at at
how positive the response is to getting
out of Afghanistan and to moving on and
and I really had a great conversation
with him today is to meet the meeting
today give in the clustering water
so actually as we have been educating
health care providers really from day
one back in January about the need to be
on guard against respiratory syndrome
and then when we had this case of the
long term care facility in Washington we
sent out special alerts to long-term
care facilities to be very mindful about
infection control isolation with these
most vulnerable of our seniors and other
individuals who have comorbid conditions
and that's really what we've been seeing
around the world is the prevalence of
fatalities have been in the elderly and
those who have other forms of medical
fragility comorbid conditions and so
really being on very high alert in our
nursing home community is called for mr.
secretary could you talk about your
meeting with lawmakers today and what
specifically they're asking of the
federal government what's their biggest
concern well I think it's the same
concern that we've all had which is
getting testing out there rapidly into
the community so that we can be testing
as many people as possible as you know
our excellent teams down at the CDC
developed the test really in record time
within weeks of getting the genetic
sequence back in January and we approved
the diagnostic and CDs at the FDA under
an emergency use authorization and
record time we've been able to be
testing at CDC throughout without any
backlog in testing our throughput has
been great there we've had 12 labs
qualified to be able to do the testing
we did suffer a manufacturing issue on
that test as it went out to the rest of
the public health labs we've gotten that
issue solved in the last week so that's
up and running in the public health labs
we also have gotten this test produced
by a this contractor to get it out so we
will this week have up to 70 75 thousand
tests shipping out there to public
health labs as well as available to
hospitals ordering and then something
really important happened on Saturday
morning so one of the biggest issues
around testing that people don't
understand is during the Obama
administration the FDA for the first
time asserted control and regular
taury jurisdiction over what are called
lab developed tests before that if a
hospital or a lab like a like a quest
Diagnostics a lab core or an academic
medical center would develop a test on
their own with reagents and tests they
could just do that if they were a
certified clinical lab called a CLIA lab
but under the obama administration the
fda asserted jurisdiction and said you
have to come to us first and get
approval of that test before you can do
it on Saturday morning Commissioner Hahn
issued guidance saying under an
emergency use authorization we are
permitting these labs these public
health labs these hospital labs
commercial labs to go ahead get the test
going do your own tests make it
available and come to us for approval
after the fact under berteus
authorization that will make this
Commissioner honest said millions of
tests per week available quite rapidly
mr. secretary can I ask you about the
study from the CDC today that showed the
Americans most at risk of contracting
coronavirus are the ones with people
living with patients so should Americans
be less worried about catching the virus
from say people on the street or people
on an airport so what we said at the
press conference just yesterday is very
consistent with that which is for the
average American in your daily life the
risk of getting corona viral Crona virus
is very low but if you are around
individuals who have the novel
coronavirus the risk obviously is higher
and that's why the efforts were taking
with the state of Washington and with
Santa Clara County and elsewhere in the
country are around what's called
community mitigation which is to isolate
individuals who have the disease as well
as to reduce social contact to bring the
level of disease spreading down mr.
president I don't know if you had seen
reports about the the Vice President
having shaken hands with students from a
Florida school one of whom had been
placed into voluntary self quarantine
did that concern you at all what did you
think about that I haven't seen that
report
well we're gonna look at the uninsured
because they have a big problem we're
gonna look at the uninsured people that
you know this came as a surprise to all
of us just happened to chose what can
happen in life but we're gonna be
looking at the uninsured see if we can
help them out work as part of the
emergency supplemental we'll work with
Congress on programs to help hospitals
as they care for the uninsured with
novel coronavirus thank you over
[Music]
my get it done
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my get it done
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]